salut tout le monde un nouvel épisode de
notre série consacrée aux prospect de la
draft NBA 2023 en 20 minutes on vous
donne l'essentiel à savoir sur sur ces
jeunes qui se présentent donc on fait
les portraits des environs des 20
premiers selon notre propre classement
plus plus des Français évidemment pour
cet épisode on vous donne l'essentiel
sur Jordan Hawkins
Jordan Hawkins
né le 29 avril 2002 donc il a déjà 21
ans il jouait sa deuxième saison en NCIS
cette saison du côté de Yukon
Connecticut 1m96 84 kg 2 mètres
d'envergure selon le très récent NBA
draft combine pour en parler Manu et
Hugues bonjour bonsoir à toutes et à
tous pas mieux très inclusif très
inclusif c'est vrai c'est beau pour
commencer comme d'habitude on va vous
donner la biographie les choses à savoir
sur la personne qui est Jordan Hawkins
Hugh c'est toi qui t'en charge
yes alors Jordan Hawkins au-delà d'être
mon chouchou c'est un garçon qui a
grandi dans le Maryland
qui a fait son lycée là-bas il a été
nommé au baril de boisson sucrée de
l'année je sais plus ce que c'est gâteau
Coca-Cola un peu importe et il a été
recruté assez tôt par les par les
programmes beaucoup de programmes de la
Ligue is d'ailleurs market ça veut dire
cet homme all youcon etc donc qui a fait
cette région était prédestinée c'est une
recrute quatre étoiles donc on est en
dehors du Top 20 top 25 globalement
lycéen c'est pas un joueur qui était
énormément sur les radars il fait une
première année à Yukon sortie de banc
dans une équipe assez compétitive avec
des mecs comme thaï with meltin qui joue
qui en tout et player NBA du coup tu as
le temps là par exemple et RG coach qui
je pense est fini en Europe c'est un
joueur qui avait un rôle de pyromane et
puis deuxième saison sauf aux morts il
explose c'est leader offenser son équipe
sont parlé de son jeu et il va pouvoir
aller jusqu'au bout il est il est
champion avec cette équipe des Huskies
et une belle équipe compétitive avec
plusieurs joueurs profils professionnels
voir NBA et sa cote à l'expose et du
coup
il s'annonce à la draft et il est
attendu attendu assez notre ami Jordan
deuxième prénom Jordan Dorel Hawkins et
je vois qu'il a un une cousine qui joue
au basket aussi à ls you qui est un gros
programme pour les féminines parce que
les parents ne sont pas ne sont pas des
gros des gros sportifs mais les parents
voulaient des enfants joueurs
professionnels de basket notamment le
papa qui
met la pression un petit peu où il papa
il dit moi quand il est né j'ai fait une
photo avec un ballon de basket je viens
tous ces matchs dit que mon fils il sera
joueur de NBA à tout le monde depuis
qu'il est né donc bon bah le papa va
voir son se réaliser et le Jordanie n'a
pas des grandes épaules physiquement par
contre mentalement il a déjà bien bouffé
et donc oui parce qu'elle est Siwa a
gagné cette année au niveau de la NCF
féminine donc aucune c'est sa cousine
ont été tous les deux champions
NCA à deux jours d'intervalle c'est
quand même assez beau
on va parler du rôle qu'avait Jordan
Hawkins tu l'as touché un mot Hugues
mais Manu qu'est-ce qu'on lui demande de
faire en attaque cette année et en
défense aussi quel rôle il avait dans
cette équipe de Yukon qui a donc été
championne
c'était l'option numéro une de Yukon
déjà au tirant dans le scoring c'est là
où il s'agit ça lui permet d'avoir un
taux d'usage moi qui m'a impressionné de
23% je pensais pas qu'il était aussi
haut et c'est du fait qu'en fait qu'il a
plein de tirs il avait énormément de
tiers du fait de sa qualité de sa saison
qui a été incroyable
et du coup plus du
je sais pas si on dit maintenant mais
plus du obscreen
beaucoup de systèmes pour lui en sortie
d'écran un peu à la calgale chez à
Virginia ou voilà tout était mis en
place pour lui pour pour l'attaque et ça
c'était aussi ce qui l'a rendu parce
qu'il a mis dans 38 % à 3 points cette
année ce qui est juste incroyable
alors sur un volume énorme 15 15 3
points par 100 possession c'est énorme
ouais c'est juste incroyable plus un peu
plus en de ça
peut-être du fait du spacing et NCM est
uniquement 32% à deux points enfin dans
la dans la zone minerai-je en fait alors
que
c'est assez intéressant c'est qu'il a
aussi pu aller au Cercle moi je le
trouvais pas suffisamment mais il a pu
le faire avec un joli personnage de 55 %
de réussite près du cercle donc c'est
vraiment intéressant de l'avoir vu
pouvoir scorer sur tous les niveaux ces
trois niveaux là tout au long de la
saison avec une vraie régularité à trois
points
et défensivement ça défendait sur qui le
meilleur joueur adverse le deuxième
meilleur dans le cacher un peu comment
se passait non c'est un défenseur
honnête moi j'ai trouvé sur la sur toute
la saison plus sur des plus capables de
défendre sur des sur des gardes de fait
de sa taille et de son envergure qui est
pas
et correct sans plus
mais voilà c'est TF1 sur honnête sans
être le bluegaï qu'on peut que peut être
exemple
ultimatum un kawaii ou un Power tu vois
ce genre de
ça va être un défenseur honnête avoir
l'adaptation NBA face à des joueurs
beaucoup plus toujours pareil beaucoup
plus rapide beaucoup plus costaud on va
voir comment il va savoir gérer ça et je
pense qu'on aime bien par contre ça va
être plus là je m'avance un peu mais
plus sur du meneur 1 voire que du meneur
ou voir du du 1 2 en défense super
il est léger 84 kg c'est pas lourd quand
tu arrives à NBA après on sait qu'il
prenne tous du poids c'est pas forcément
le
mais il a pas des une grosse structure
osseuse ou musculaire il peut ajouter du
poids mais enfin ça c'est mon avis mais
je
quand on le regarde on se dit pas c'est
un gars qui va mettre 20 kg de muscle
là-dessus quoi
pas très large d'épaule pourquoi on
draft Jordan Hawkins c'est le moment où
j'ai oublié de dire où il était situé
dans la au moment où on parle on
enregistre le 25 mai là un mois avant la
draft
17ème dans le Big board donc bigboard
c'est vraiment les classements de valeur
c'est pas en fonction de qui choisit à
cette position là 17e chez yatletic
25ème the Ringer 13e chez espian vous
vous l'avez à quelle position sur vos
bornes messieurs Hugues dans le top 10
je crois moi je l'ai dans mon troisième
ouais 3e tiers
bordure 4e tiers on est sur le entre 8
et 8 et 12 quoi ok Manu
je sais plus je sais plus bon je crois
qu'il était entre 10 et 15 de toute
façon il était peut-être 10e remarque
enfin il est il est borderline top 10
chez nous il est un peu plus haut que
chez les autres même si espiane là c'est
haut Hugues pourquoi on draft Jordan
Hawkins quand on est un GM NBA
pourquoi la première chose c'est que tu
sais que tu pourras le faire jouer il va
t'apporter du spacing c'est un gars qui
va toujours être une là sur le terrain
c'est pas simplement un sirop de 4chan
chute on a parlé du gros volume de 3
points mais c'est pas qu'un mec qui va
réceptionner tirer c'est un gars qui est
tout le temps mouvement infatigable qui
court effectivement derrière les écrans
qui se déplacent très très bien sur les
sur le latéral pour pouvoir derrière et
axer se retourner c'est un joueur qui va
être une une vraie menace qui va créer
du spaceing qui au-delà de ça au-delà du
tir est un bon joueur de cut alors
effectivement très léger mais va
apporter de la diversité très bon dans
le hand of très bon dans la manipulation
donc tordan Hawkins c'est réussir à
donner de la variété à ton équipe assez
facilement sans faire grand chose juste
avec des bons écrans et puis
je me dis après si voilà mais pour moi
il y a il y a un vrai potentiel à
développer dans la création individuelle
pour l'instant tu le drive parce que tu
sais que tu vas avoir du du spécifique
et beaucoup de tirs vraiment beaucoup de
tiens Manu sur le le la gestuelle le tir
en soit tu te fais tu es d'accord avec
Hugues c'est vraiment le le gros attrait
de Jordan Hawkins c'est et pourquoi on
aime son tir si c'est si effectivement
le pour toi le gros attrait également
ouais c'est difficile de passer ben en
fait comme il a été dans une situation
beaucoup de shoot et qui les a mis c'est
difficile après cette saison là de dire
autre chose que son tir en fait après on
peut creuser et dire
voilà il y a toujours un peu plus moi je
pense que moi personnellement on baisse
caisse scénario pour moi c'est un Jamal
Murray
j'imagine avoir cette évolution là c'est
un gars qui va au Fury au fur et à
mesure des années apprendre à devenir un
porteur numéro 1 et à gérer à une équipe
c'est comme ça que je le pour moi
meilleur des meilleurs scénarios quoi il
a le handle pour ça il a pimmerait quand
même ouais costaud ça va au cercle il a
le le skills pour aller à ce niveau là
la grosse différence entre c'est
vraiment le physique ou Murray était
vraiment déjà assez carré en cookie et
on voyait qu'il avait de la place pour
pour ajouter contrairement à un Jordan
Hawking c'est vraiment ça la grosse
différence mais en fait moi j'ai envie
d'y croire parce que je me dis qu'un
joueur avec ce potentiel là au tir faut
le développer autrement faut qu'il
devienne attractif pour son équipe
autres parce que
je travaille pas un top 10 si le gars va
m'apporter que du tiers
on peut on peut dire ça ou il faut faire
comme comme realen l'été un genre ultra
athlétique
le realen de Yukon et de Milwaukee est
juste incroyable et c'est après avec la
l'âge un peu comme au foot où il a
commencé à reculer et c'est devenu une
gâchette ultime mais moi je vois un peu
ce truc là pour moi faut que ce soit
l'inverse qu'il arrive encore un plus à
ce poste se projeter du coup vers le
cercle et apprendre à aujourd'hui ça on
pourra pas attaquée
le moyen c'est pas c'est pas ouf ouf
mais moi j'ai vu des flashs qui me
disent que ce Best caisse scénario là il
est il est valable mais il faut encore
une fois le fameux contexte
on y viendra
ça peut être très compliqué
tu vois le je pense aussi qu'il y avait
le fait qu'il a eu quand c'est ce qu'on
lui a demandé de faire cette année si
vous regardez l'an dernier parce que
j'étais je l'avais déjà montré l'an
dernier moi si vous regardez l'an
dernier où il est sorti de banc et qu'il
est un peu frustré par ce rôle
d'ailleurs de d'avoir très peu de temps
de jeu de 10 minutes 12 minutes et à la
fin de trop jouer il fait plein de
choses il fait plein de choses
différentes regardez son battle for
Atlantis qui est un tournoi de début de
saison où il joue Michigan State et
Obernai il y a beaucoup de création
individuelles il y a beaucoup de jeux de
pull-up il y a beaucoup de de
projections vers le panier avec un
double pas où il arrive à vraiment
traverser toute la ligne c'est trop
jusqu'au cercle on a un double pas très
long il a vraiment une une très belle
allonge moi une envergure pas énorme et
je pense vraiment que le contexte tu
connais excellent mis en avant sur le
tir mais à cacher d'autres choses de son
jeu parce que on disait assez fin il y a
32 % de puissance
ce qui est ouais ce qui est assez élevé
pour un gars qui prend que 20% du cercle
alors il est il a le 4 points de Jamal
Crawford le tir à trois points et la
faute il en fait un par match enfin
vraiment il est très très bon là-dessus
pour faire piéger la défense mais il
provoque aussi pas mal de lancer francs
près du panier il a une vraie bonne
projection donc je rejoins aussi le rôle
le lance pas c'est un créateur pour
collectif en tant que premier option par
contre horreur vraiment important dans
plusieurs situations dans un rôle mais
alors je dis pas que c'est réel mais
dans ce rôle là que ne Manu parle ou
bien quelque chose que voilà que nous a
montré bah effectivement peut-être un
toit Alexandre II en développement cette
année ou un Michael bridges en
développement
à Brooklyn en fin de saison voilà
peut-être un peu plus un peu plus terre
à terre mais j'y crois vraiment
fortement Michael bridges a pu
développer ça parce qu'il a eu du temps
de jeu il a eu du temps de jeu parce que
c'est un excellent défenseur au-delà de
de maintenance à son niveau offensif
qu'en est-il de Jordan Hawkins
le problème c'est que son anokin il est
tout maigre et que Yukon développe assez
mal le physique sur les premières années
c'est pas c'est pas une école
c'est pas un premier enfin c'est il est
assez vieux entre guillemets pour un
joueur qu'on projette top 10
école James booknight avait fait 2 ans
aussi et pas pris énormément de masse
alors James secrets tu as pas une grosse
début de carrière
la prise de masse est pas et pas
optimale quand tu vois un mec dans
l'équipe comme Audrey Jackson qui arrive
et qui tient une belle bête physique à
son entraîneci et du coup aujourd'hui
ouais c'est ça qui lui pour le coup
était le stoppeur défensif qui était
l'homme à tout faire
voilà attends Jackson qui arrive est une
belle bête déjà physique et il sort de
de Yukon où il sortira du Yukon et la
pas tant évolué que ça donc je sais pas
si la fac axe vraiment là dessus en tout
cas mais pas trop l'accent dessus mais
pour le moment NBA il défend personne en
première année parce que trop maigre à
terme je suis assez d'accord avec Manu
pour stopper sur les postes 1 2 parce
que très vif il a une bonne latéralité
il bouge bien bon changement d'appui
agressif très agressif des mains très
actives une mentalité aussi de tueurs il
aime bien ça il aime bien venir chiper
le ballon de venir te mettre une presse
venir te coller donne des bons angles il
s'est bien orienté main droite main
gauche côté report assez assez sérieux
il fait pas énormément de fautes donc
j'y crois avec un développement physique
mais encore une fois le watif c'est
est-ce que tu peux passer la barre des
95 kg d'ici trois ans
est-ce qui est-ce qui l'aura assez
d'efficacité offensive selon toi Manu
pour surmonter au début
peut-être son inefficacité défensive et
on le répète pour pour ceux qui nous
écoutent pas depuis des années vous êtes
tout pardonné mais
les Rouky NBA qui sont positifs pour
leur équipe en défense c'est genre je
sais pas trois ou quatre sur 60 par
année quoi très très rare c'est vraiment
extrêmement rare sauf dans les classes
de draft de ma boule où il y a des
veines meublés et compagnies mais sinon
playoff il reste un Rocky qui a un vrai
rôle Christian Brown
après là il reste que deux équipes donc
élargir sur les autres tours c'est
vraiment le seul qui a eu un vrai rôle
tout au long des playoffs tout à fait
c'est aussi grâce à sa défense notamment
tout à fait du coup qu'est-ce que tu en
penses Manu sur le côté ce qui est-ce
qu'il aura tu vois est-ce qu'il a la
diversité parce que ok il va falloir
qu'il développe son offens mais en
attendant sa défense sera pas sera pas
extraordinaire est-ce que juste avec ce
qui s'est fait maintenant en fait et ce
qu'il aura pour toi du temps de jeu dès
l'année prochaine
moi j'ai du mal à le projeter comme ça
honnêtement même s'il est il est intense
il est voilà il bouge super bien et tout
il a envie mais j'ai du mal c'est
vraiment unique principalement
physiquement je le vois si il garde son
corps ça peut très bien changer en
quelques mois les staff NBA seront
savent travailler mais j'ai dû là
aujourd'hui j'ai du mal à le projeter
comme ça je pense qu'il va faire pas mal
de Tours jelly et qu'il apprenne
parce que je pense
qui pourra versus des joueurs type
physiquement la mélomo tu vois des
joueurs comme ça physiquement qui
en termes de kilos ça doit être plus ou
moins la même chose
costaud lamelle mais oui et sur le fond
pas trop pépette tu vois je le vois plus
défendre sur des joueurs comme ça que
sur par exemple un gars comme comme
Facebook ou même un Jamal Murra qui sont
beaucoup plus étoffés beaucoup plus
épais et lourd ou là je pense que il
aura du mal ou il faudra qu'il domine
tout de suite par son intensité ça la
télé-réalité
et je pense que le spaceing aime bien va
pas l'aider
Hugues toi qu'est-ce que tu penses de
son rôle probable en année un quel
environnement tu imagines idéal pour
pour son développement sans en citant ou
pas une équipe on n'est pas obligé
pour moi son rôle ça va être sorti de
banc
donner du spacing sur les postes il va
jouer dans les relais des extérieurs des
arrières liées de trois sur 10 15
minutes et j'espère une équipe qui va
avoir du mouvement de jeu loin du ballon
je préférerais quelque chose comme ça
pas une équipe qui est trop égocentrée
alors après j'ai regardé un petit peu là
le la loterie
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup d'équipes qui ont des
très très bons extérieurs alors je vois
Dallas en 10 alors pour le coup qui est
très éluocentré
il va se régaler de quatre chaînes shoot
bien propre quoi c'est ça et c'est ça et
puis il y a quand même quelques écrans
loin du ballon et cetera donc ça j'aime
bien je voilà je ne faut pas lui donner
de responsabilité ballonnement faut le
faire sortir du banc une équipe un peu
compétitive je pense que ça peut lui
réussir parce que on a on a vu une
première année où lorsqu'il sort du banc
et qui joue pas et que on le frustre il
prend des mauvais tirs il a tendance à
vouloir chauffer c'est quand même un
gros caractère je pense que l'éducation
a dû jouer là-dedans tu dois être bon tu
dois être un peu une star un peu
tu vois que je voyais de l'interview des
vannes Fournier avec son papa ça
ressemble un peu à ça sans que ça soit
toxique il y a une vraie présence quoi
t'as pas le droit de perdre tu as le
temps tu vas te compétitif et tout ça et
donc voilà faut faut si tu le sort du
banc va falloir en loterie va falloir
pouvoir lui montrer pourquoi donc
j'aimerais bien une équipe un peu un
minimum compétitif
Manu sur les attitudes le mental est-ce
que tu as relevé quelque chose en
particulier ce qui est normal ce qu'il
est je sais pas qu'est-ce que tu as pu
voir
non c'est un gars moi je trouve vraiment
concentré dans ce qu'il fait
sérieusement bref il faut le voir en
vrai faut le voir à l'entraînement faut
le voir dans d'autres choses mais sur le
ce qu'on a en vidéo moi je le trouve
assez assez focus dans ce qu'il fait pas
trop de perte de mémoire de perte de
vision tu vois ou de perte de
concentration
si vraiment un gars qui a assez
concentré dans tout ce qu'il fait que
soit on attaque ou en défense
l'attitude franchement l'attitude comme
ça globale de ce qu'on peut voir à notre
petite échelle c'est c'est plutôt
correct
Hugues tu ne mets trivia alerte dans ton
dans notre chat dis-moi c'est une petite
question non non
il fait une demi-finale de tournoi de
mars Madness sous comment dire infection
alimentaire il a un bouffé un truc pas
frais et du calamar et il a dit et il
nous fait le calamary Game deuxième
mi-temps il prend feu il porte l'équipe
et tout alors que ben il a hyper
malobine et qui participe à
l'entraînement et il reste avec des
pourcentages de ouf au tiers donc dans
le côté focus compétitif je joue peu
importe etc je trouve que c'est c'est un
petit fun fact mais qui a son importance
quoi
est-ce que vous y croyez c'est la
question
qui vaut des points messieurs je m'amuse
avec oui
depuis le début moi je suis un homme
autant
selon le contexte tu penses qu'il est
selon le contexte
et je suis aussi même j'ai vraiment peur
que
qu'il n'arrive pas à se développer autre
chose que son tir et du coup il soit et
qui deviennent pas évidemment pas un
shooter élite il a pas cette cette
corpulence il a pas le physique pour il
est trop petit et je trouve je peur
qu'il devienne très très vite limité en
fait et qu'on se retrouve avec un James
booknabis
c'était notre présentation de Jordan
Hawkins le joueur de Yukon vous pouvez
aller voir son scooting report sur
envergure.co vous pouvez la consulter
tous nos autres portraits les essentiels
sur les autres joueurs de cette draft
NBA 2023 avec évidemment toute une série
de podcasts consacrés aussi à Victor
webba Niyama qui devrait partir numéro 1
salut tout le monde